[Inaudible].
You all know this, the United States has a problem with racism,
and this was evident long before the murder of George Floyd.
Racism has been debated in this country for decades,
and it's a debate that's been argued from left to, right?
But United States is not the only country that has a racism problem.
Just take a look.
Black people in China,
banned from McDonald's and evicted from their homes over coronavirus fears.
And this is just one example. In reality,
racism is a phenomenon that occurs in many countries and with all kinds of races
from India to Rwanda all the way to China.
And you're probably wondering of all the countries in the world.
Why did we want to focus on China to make this video? Well it's for two reasons,
the first is that in recent months,
China has shooted itself in anti-racism rhetoric's to push its foreign policy
during the coronavirus crisis. Every time a country closed borders with China,
that country was accused of being racist.
China's Israel, Envoy compares virus, travel bands to Holocaust.
However, when it comes to racism,
China is not a country that can preach to us about it without digging too deep,
just four years ago, Chinese television itself broadcast an advert like this.
[Inaudible].
And joke say, but how many black people are there in China?
Are we really talking about an oppressed minority?
Is there really a problem with dark skinned people in China? Well,
the truth is that yes, there is, but it's not the worst case of racism.
As we said in the beginning, white people,
aren't the only racists just as blacks. Aren't the only victims of racism.
In reality,
the largest and most oppressed minority are neither black people nor Hispanics.
We're talking about the or minority. Believe me. If China had freedom of speech,
there would be some movement called [inaudible] lives matter,
and you don't believe me. Well, just take a look at this.
The fate of weaker Muslims in China, from reeducation camps to.
And this leads us to talk about the second reason we're making this video.
What we are going to tell you has received hardly any media attention yet it
puts China's current actions on par with apartheid in South Africa. In fact,
even we were surprised while doing the research for this video,
the more details we discovered,
the more terrible it seemed to us to give you an idea.
China's government recognizes 56 ethnic groups within its immense.
In addition, only one of these groups,
the Han ethnic group represents more than 90% of the population while the other
50 minority groups make up less than 10% could bind so far. So good, right?
This means that they recognize diversity.
There must be specific rights for minorities. Yes, but no.
If you are a Chinese citizen,
your national identity card has to state what ethnicity or minority group you
belong to. And it's not just any old bit of paper.
What you put in the ethnicity box can have very, very real consequences.
For example, in the Xinjiang autonomous region,
the only one in which the ego population predominates the authorities have
collected images, fingerprints,
Iris captures DNA and biometric data from each and every resident of the
region since 2017. And if you're a resident of Xinjiang,
it's not like you've been asked for your consent or that you can refuse to give
a DNA sample. If you do not participate in the regional database,
not only do you not have access to the most basic documentation,
but you can be charged with disloyalty to the room.
Jean.
It happens. You're going to be forced to go through a re-education program,
which in some cases basically means a concentration.
There are even several accusations of racism with many organizations comparing
China's treatment of the, your girls to the Nazis treatment of Jews.
And we're not talking about groups of dangerous neo-liberal capitalists who hate
to China,
but about organizations like human rights watch and the European parliament.
So is there really racism in China is racism really supported by the government
itself? Why, who is the hardest hit today?
We're going to answer these questions,
but first let's have a look at some history.
Chosen, right?
You may be surprised to hear this,
but almost 30% of the Chinese population does not speak Mandarin Chinese.
When we think of China, we tend to think of a gigantic,
super homogenous country where everyone is equal. They are all Chinese speak,
Mandarin Chinese and follow Chinese traditions. Well,
that is not the case at all.
Today's China is a country of almost 1.4 billion people.
It's a relatively young country,
at least in terms of its current borders and political system.
And there are whole regions that don't have Chinese culture or anything
resembling it mainly to Tibet and the Xinjiang region
In these two regions,
it's the Han Chinese that are the minority race and almost the entire population
speaks local languages. Just so you know,
there are more than 300 different languages in China.
And we're talking about languages that sometimes are not even related to each
other. For example, the legal language does not even use Chinese characters,
but is an adaptation of the Arabic alphabet in Hong Kong. Cantonese has spoken,
which is not anything like Mandarin to give you an idea.
We're talking about languages as different from each other as Spanish or Brown.
Sure.
This has been China's great obsession, not just from the time of communism,
but since time immemorial,
the very first political attempts to centralize and unify China date back to the
third century BC and collimated 200 years later during the Han empire.
Agile, probably thinking who are the hunts.
Behind are the typical Chinese.
You imagine they have Chinese facial features speak Mandarin Chinese and
represent Chinese culture and tradition while they make up to 92% of the
population.
There are two regions where they are not the majority population in Tibet.
The hand make up only 8% of the population.
And in Jinjiang just over 38%, however, even in these regions,
the Han historically held the position. Yeah.
For a time.
The balance between Chinese ethnicities and conquered peoples was more or less
easy to maintain.
China was a feudal country with a hierarchical political system in which
everyone had a clear idea of their social role.
Things changed in the 20th century, the Chinese sleeping dragon awoke,
and found a problem.
How do we build a modern nation state with so many peoples that see us as
invaders? The solution of the first president of the Republic of China was easy.
We are going to tell minorities that not only must we be friends,
but we must come from the same origin,
the Han empire of more than two millennia.
Go.
This part of the story was rewritten by Chinese leaders as if they were writers
of a soap opera.
[inaudible] Well, there it is. John Paul,
we can't keep fighting because I just found out we're cousins.
So what's the problem that this rhetoric apart from being historically false,
continued to place the hunt as the favorite sons in the great Chinese family.
Meanwhile,
minorities had to reinvent themselves to earn the affection of the mother
Republic. Then Mao arrives and take stock of the situation.
He simplifies the Chinese characters to facilitate the learning of the common
language and advances in the construction of a United people,
but as good a parents, he no longer has favorite children.
The idea of Han supremacy was extended to political and social levels,
to such an extent that even the Chinese constitution itself recognizes Han
chauvinism as a threat.
In the struggle to safeguard the unity of the nationalities.
It is necessary to combat big nation chauvinism, mainly Han chauvinism,
and to combat local national chauvinism extract from the preamble of the Chinese
constitution.
While the Han were off the pedestal, the constitution recognized some cultural,
social and linguistic rights of ethnic minorities.
And in some cases they might even seem like privileges. For example,
while the Han Chinese had to comply with the one child policy,
minorities could have two or even three children. And you're probably thinking,
so why are they complaining?
Well as always the devil is in the details as we'll see right now.
No country for hipsters.
In recent years, it has become fashionable to wear a beard. However,
if I were an oil girl lived in Jean Jang and wore a beard, I would have a huge,
huge problem. Why?
Because it would be red as an indication that I'm most likely a radical
extremist. At least that's what the Beijing government.
Thinks.
China Wiggers detained for beards, veils and internet Brown.
And then you have it. We're not only talking about beards,
but also about a woman who covers her head, a person practices,
religious rights or someone who visits foreign websites.
But that is at the end of it.
You can also be arrested for visiting relatives outside to China,
or even for buying food with a HELOC.
Label.
As you can see,
most of these restrictions are somehow associated with Islam and they are
designed precisely to reduce the importance of this religion in Chinese society.
And you'll say, but surely you're making it up. Josh,
you're telling us this because you're buying into America's neo-liberal
propaganda. Well,
the truth is that what I'm telling you is actually the official rhetoric's in
Beijing. In fact, the Chinese communist party justifies their actions like this.
Yes.
And Western Xinjiang region has written vocational training centers for Muslim
Wiggers into law,
a mid growing international concern over large-scale disappearances.
There is a young says the centers will tackle extremism through thought
transformation.
[Inaudible] transformation may sound like something from 1984, but don't forget.
We're talking about a dictatorship,
many things that are considered unacceptable in a democratic society are
commonplace in China. And you're probably wondering, but how did that happen?
Didn't you just say that China accepted diversity and recognize the cultural
linguistic and religious rights of these minorities? Well,
let's go back a moment in time and return to the constitution.
On one hand in 1982 constitution recognizes ethnic diversity,
the rights of minorities and the right of all citizens to profess their
religious beliefs. But on the other hand,
it is expressly forbidden to use religion,
to threaten unity among Chinese nationalities.
And this is something that in practice can mean anything. For example,
you can shout long, lived China and nothing happens.
But if you shouted long-lived Tibet,
you would be guaranteed at least one unforgettable night to behind bars.
In fact, the regime prohibits any kind of nationalist movements. What's more,
there are even legal changes that contradict the constitution itself.
For example,
even if minorities have the rights on the paper to receive education in their
own languages. In recent years,
there were decrees that teaching in some regions should only be undertaken in
Mandarin Chinese.
And let's see who dares to denounce the Chinese government in the courts here.
However, we go far beyond political and linguistic rights.
It's about to get a lot darker.
Listen up.
Scientists, debate China's law on sterilizing, the carriers of genetic defects.
We've all heard about the one child policy.
It was enforced between 1979 and 2015.
What is not so well known is that there is also a law that forces certain
couples to abort, potential offspring, or even be sterilized.
Initially the maternal child health act of 1994 is based on a brutal
interpretation of public health.
Basically if a couple has any kind of inherited physical or mental illness and
not allowed to reproduce. So in order to get married,
you have to prove that you have been sterilized.
The same law also speaks of defective fetuses in which case,
termination of the pregnancy is recommended.
And I'm guessing you can probably imagine what recommendations are like in the
Chinese regime by now. Some of you will be thinking that this all can't be true,
but think about it. We're talking about a very non individualistic country.
That is a place where it is understood that citizens are indebted above all to
the collective good under this logic. Many of these things are consistent,
consistent in a strange way. Yes,
but no one can say that China isn't true to itself,
but let's get back to the topic of racism because if sterilization seem barbaric
to you,
look at this quote from the former Chinese public health minister speaking in
1990.
[Inaudible].
Or quality births are important among ancient revolutionary basis among ethnic
minorities in border areas. And in economically marginalized areas,
Chen min Jong minister of public health in 1994.
There are ethnic minorities that produced lower quality births in practice.
This means that it is ethnic minorities who suffer most of the forced
sterilizations. For example,
while the law technically allows to veterans to have more than one child,
it also forced many couples of this race to be sterilized.
There have been many cases where women were sterilized without even knowing what
operation they were being subjected to.
And we're not just talking about isolated cases here,
according to a university of Michigan paper and 1995,
more than 3% of Tibetan women would have undergone these operations.
If you think this is a horrific state of affairs, you've not seen anything yet.
This country, we speak Chinese.
As we have explained several times on this channel,
Jingping is a reversal in everything that is to do with Chinese openness while
it is true that in many respects,
China was opening itself more to the world and recognizing citizens rights.
If only economically Xi Jinping came up with a very clear idea about the legal
status of ethnic minorities. What did he do?
Something which might initially seem to be good news.
He abolished the one child policy.
Trying to end one child policy, allowing families to have two children.
This means that the hand could automatically have more than one child.
But what about minorities?
Do you remember Danielle Ping's famous phrase that it didn't matter if the cat
was black or white while hunting mice well, Gigi pink doesn't care anymore.
What the Chinese president is looking for is precisely what's the preamble to
his constitution for bids to standardize the country under the dominance of hand
culture. This term was a major setback for ethnic minorities,
where before the maternal and child health act of 1994,
pay for the way for the sterilization of some minority people,
jeez government began to apply eugenic policies across the board.
And the most effected group have been the audience.
[Inaudible].
China cuts weaker births with [inaudible] abortion and sterilization.
But it's not just that. If you remember,
GJ ping uses super nationalist rhetoric for him, unity is very important.
And when we talk about Chinese nationalism, what we mean is this.
Religions must be subordinate to communist party.
And what does all this mean that Chinese communists will tolerate religion as
long as they get to choose the religious leaders.
We have seen it with the Catholic church,
which was the bid in China until Pope Francis made a pact with Gigi pink.
Basically China accepted the authority of the Vatican in exchange for diplomatic
favors, but other religious minorities have not been so lucky.
And that's the case with the way girls,
the autonomous region of Xinjiang is the only place in China where [inaudible]
ethnicity predominance. And as you know,
the main difference between oysters and the Han Chinese is that the girls are
mostly Muslim and use Arabic script.
The patient government is willing to do anything to erase these differences.
And you'll say, how would they go about doing this? Well,
among other things through education in 2017 for language teaching was banned in
all schools in Jing Jang. And two years later,
the use of the Arabic alphabet in public spaces was bad.
Of course looked at from the outside, from the Western perspective,
we could easily call this cultural genocide,
but the Chinese government doesn't believe that he's doing anything wrong.
The way they see it. These laws are helping oysters integrate.
Think about it from this point of view,
the official language in China is Mandarin Chinese.
If you want to integrate into Chinese society,
increase your job opportunities and live the Chinese dream.
The first thing you have to do is learn the official language.
Does it make some sense? It does, right?
At first it might even seem like good politics.
China is using every means at its disposal. So that oil goes,
can become Han Chinese, fully fledged Chinese. I mean,
it's not just a racial issue. They're saying, okay,
you want to be part of the Chinese dream. No problem.
We're going to teach you Chinese. So what's the problem.
The problem is in the methods being used to motivate, or it goes to integrate.
Chairman report spells out China human rights abuses against a weaker Muslims.
These human rights violations occur in some very specific places,
which Beijing calls reeducation camps.
It is estimated that there are at least 500 in the Jinjiang region.
So what exactly are they for? Well,
as the name suggests to reeducate Muslim minorities and bring them culturally
closer to the Han ethnic group,
these are supposedly vocational training centers and the official photos looked
like language Academy.
Textbook covers a lot of happy young students smiling at the camera.
And the question is, do you think girls are happy in these camps? Well,
the truth is no. And reeducation is nothing like a voluntary process.
[Inaudible] proof of this is that.
In many of these centers, there are entire arsenals of tear, gas, stun,
guns and handcuffs. And I don't know about you,
but it's hard for me to understand how you can educate with those things.
And of course, oil goes who have managed to escape. Reeducation camps,
denounced them as dens of torture abuse of all kinds of violence,
but it's not just about what's going on behind locked Gates.
As I told you at the beginning,
Xinjiang residents are required to provide a series of biometric data to
authorities from fingerprints to DNA samples,
something that does not happen to the same degree in the rest of the country.
What's more,
China is increasingly successful in developing and implementing facial
recognition technology.
So any Iger can be recognized within seconds wherever they are. And you'll say,
but where is the racist bias if this technology is implemented in China? Well,
yes,
that's a good point until you discover that 30% of the trials were conducted
specifically by analyzing Olga facial features.
All of this is worrying when you consider that goes account for only 0.7,
6% of the total Chinese population at this point,
many of you will think that it simply can't be true. He must be making this up.
And you might think that except for the fact that China actually justifies these
policies.
[Inaudible].
The Chinese government typically uses three arguments to explain defending their
actions, reason. Number one, it's our country.
Don't interfere in what we do too.
We're trying to prevent Islamic terrorism because oil goes are Muslims and
therefore could be radicalized.
And three we're helping minorities integrate better.
That'd be part of China's great dream. We may have some way extreme methods,
but we have their wellbeing at heart. However, as you can imagine,
oil goes and Tibetans just don't agree with this.
It is no surprise that oil and to better nationalist movements,
increasingly echo each other in the telling of their story.
[Inaudible].
We hear exiles push for court case, accusing China of.
Hong Kong, Xinjiang, Tibet, you and experts denounce Beijing's crack.
[Inaudible].
So now the question is over to you.
Did you know about these cases of Chinese racism?
Do you think China will be successful in imposing unity throughout the country?
What other examples of racism do you know of happening right now in other
countries, please leave your answers in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoy this video. Please hit, like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
And of course this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on
that platform,
please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice, check out the reconsidered podcast,
where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite podcast.